hey guys it's justine and today is a
very exciting video this video is
actually sponsored by lg so a huge thank
you to them for supporting my channel
and making this video possible because
this is something that i've really
wanted to do in my house for a very long
time i love technology i love smart
homes
and there were some things in my house
that weren't quite smart
like my washer my dryer thankfully most
of my tvs were smart televisions but
this one specifically has the thin-q ai
technology built into it i also
have the lg styler this is a really
interesting product and something that i
never really even thought about ever
getting for myself there's so many
different use cases for this and i think
for a lot of people this could be the
perfect solution for
not having to go to the dry cleaner i
did see this at ces so it's kind of cool
to actually have it here in my house to
get to try out so for this video we're
going to kind of focus on the thin
cue app how it integrates so well with
all of the lg appliances and gadgets
that they have in their ecosystem
so today we're going to be focusing on
the four that i just got i also got one
of the new lg velvet phones
and the best part about this is the fact
that all of these devices are able to
integrate
with one single app so not only are you
able to start and stop your washer
or the lg styler i can also control the
television right here from my phone
from the thin cue app but also something
that's kind of neat as you guys can see
behind me
on this tv this is the lg cx 77 inch
class
4k smart oled tv and you can see over
here
my dryer has 29 minutes to go my washer
is off because i just put the clothes in
the dryer
and my styler is actually doing a
sanitizer right now of some of my dog
toys well they're not my dog
they're my dog's toys and what's really
cool about this is if i'm watching tv
or i'm playing a video game i'm able to
get a notification
that will let me know when my washer is
done or my dryer or anything else that
is connected to the television if there
is notification or an alert
it'll pop up on the tv on my phone
and then i'm able to take action from
there
i'm excited about the styler for a lot
of different reasons mostly because
i actually don't own an iron and this
has a really cool refresh
steam setting so i can put in my
t-shirts or my sweaters or anything that
kind of needs a little refresh it also
sanitizes but it's not a replacement for
a washer and dryer think of this kind of
as a little refresh in between washes
also
for a lot of people who wear business
suits which i
don't ever this would be so perfect
it has this little pants press
pants crease care system to crease and
keep those slacks looking real
slackalicious
i don't know much about wearing nice
pants
i know that a lot of people do wear a
lot of nice pants
which means this is a perfect pants
solution
for your pants also for your tops and
your blazers
it's like a refrigerator for your
clothes
this is actually my kitchen right now
which works really well for me because
my laundry room is
right over there but i've seen a lot of
instances where people put this in their
closet so as you're sorting through your
clothing
you can just pop this in the styler and
it can be refreshed and ready for the
day so let's do a little demo
i'm gonna put in a few items look at
this t-shirt
wrinkled not sanitized we're gonna
put this on one of these lg styler
hangers
super fancy hang that up
this is something i'm very excited about
for a very specific use case for maybe
not everyone but
for my jujitsuki so i definitely
recommend
putting these in the washer so that it
is extra clean to have a little extra
sanitizing
can never hurt and it might get the
wrinkles out because this material is so
stiff this has so many different options
there's refresh special care for suits
pants
there's sanitary so you can put bedding
in here there's also a gentle dry
so if you have a bathing suit or
some type of thing like that you can
also do that to get that nice and dry
but the best part is it all connects
with the thin cue app we're gonna do
a light refresh here we go our steam is
preparing
and it says our estimated end time is at
8 57
am
[Music]
now obviously i can control my washer
and dryer with my app so i don't
actually have to be right next to them
but for the sake of the demonstration i
am going to show you how you can use the
thin cute app
right here next to them but i could be
on the couch i could be upstairs i could
be watching tv i could be eating a meal
at the mall check on the status of my
clothes
in the washer that's the future
hopefully in the future we can actually
go back to the mall but right now
i'm just going to enjoy doing a little
dryer action over here
so the styler is almost done it's kind
of cool because you can actually see how
much time is left on the app there is a
remote start button on here so you do
have to have that activated so you are
able to control it through your phone so
let's do a quick little
dryer action there you go
25 minutes for that speed dry and while
that's happening
let's load up some of my laundry that
i've been saving all week
for this very moment
[Music]
okay i'm gonna start my washer we have a
minute left on the styler this is cool
because it does have the remote lock so
if the remote lock is active
this will actually lock so that no one
is able to access this after you have
remote lock so you can go away
it's done the styler cycle is complete
oh my gosh let's see how our items are
oh
it feels so nice and warm and toasty in
here
it's winter right now in la so
probably won't be wearing a t-shirt
usually this material is super stiff
so this kind of made it nice and cozy
now i'm going to do a sanitary run
and i don't actually like to wash my
belt every single time that i do a class
so this can be kind of cool i can just
toss this in with any other items
maybe let's put one of maddie's toys in
there this thing he's had since he was a
baby so this is over five years old i
don't even know if i want that to touch
my belt that's saying a lot so if we do
a normal run
this takes about an hour and 28 minutes
and heavy duty for
213. i feel like we'll just do a normal
hour 28 get this
all super sanitized for me and maddie
i'll see you
soon it's also kind of cool because now
i'm here filming this video and i know
that in 26 minutes
my dryer will be ready and i can go get
my clothes so this is the app
and you can see we've got our styler our
tv and the dryer and the washer
and i can control the tv so watch this
and turn it off
oh look at that that was actually really
fast
what i really like is you can also use
your voice so i can actually just search
i just seen lg youtube unboxing
i don't even have to like i don't
actually have to type anything look at
this look at look at our options
oh my gosh this is where we are right
now look how different it looks
i still have that carpet really crazy
looking at this from so long ago
it's not even that long so right here
you can see this is where you click in
to go to your home dashboard
and this will give you an entire look at
everything that is connected to your
home i can actually go to my lg velvet
and i can screen share look at this it's
currently connecting to the mobile
device
yes except oh my gosh we're screen
sharing look there it is see this look
at this i'm controlling my phone
with my tv can you guys believe this
i'm controlling my phone
with the tv right now the best part
about this is everything is just
integrated right into your phone you can
set up different rooms you can add the
styler
the dryer and the washer all into its
own room
well thank you guys so much for watching
i would love to hear from you guys do
you have a smart home what is some
future tech that you would like to
upgrade in your home
and what do you guys think of thin cue
have any of you guys used this before do
you have any lg products that you can
potentially connect to the app
i would love to hear all of it and more
in the comments below but now
i need to go get my clothes because
they're about to be done in
14 minutes incredible